foreign
modern day successful entrepreneurs and
corporate leaders the thing they all
have in common is they excel at the
general cut and thrust of business
outsmarting the competition growing the
bottom line creating a superior product
or service
but to become a business rock star that
rarified category of a name we all know
admire you need something else
General good business Acumen isn't
enough
the thing the rock stars all have in
common is they disrupt business as usual
they look at things the way they are and
say to themselves nah that's not it
consider how we used to search and how
cumbersome the process was
Sergey Brin and Larry Page completely
transformed the way we find things and
each other and even how we buy things
and what about coffee for many of us our
morning Brew was a rather dull
experience until Howard Schultz built
Starbucks for a community of people who
wanted fancy varied social coffee
and of course I can't forget Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs two men who took
computers from Nerdy labs and into our
homes and in the case of jobs our palms
too
now I know what some of you are thinking
don't worry I will be coming to that in
a minute
so if innovated I know what you're
thinking so if if
so if innovators like these can do all
this then I believe they are up for a
new challenge a challenge that no one in
business has fully cracked yet
so today I want to talk to you about why
I think
why I feel we need a rock star of
inclusion
the diversity and inclusion agenda is
one that most of us are sold on we know
it boosts creativity and profits and
generally makes our lives richer we've
known this for a very long time but if
we're honest progress has been slow
nearly 90 percent of Fortune 500 CEOs
are white males
and in the UK where I'm from they
account for 90.4 of the top 20 roles in
ftse 100 companies
now that's the status quo that is ripe
for disruption
disruptors are not afraid of doing the
difficult they push through discomfort
when others doubt they see a better more
exciting New Way
a new way that others then emulate a new
way that eventually becomes the norm
when it comes to diversity and inclusion
we need bold disruptors who are
uncomfortable with the status quo
even if the status quo benefits them in
fact especially if the status quo
benefits them
now the general thinking around dni is
that we have to get comfortable having
uncomfortable conversations but there's
a step before that's often overlooked
before uncomfortable conversations must
come uncomfortable connections and
that's something I know a little about
I get paid
sometimes anyway I get paid to do the
two things that most people are
uncomfortable doing
public speaking and talking to strangers
now the thing is when I was a kid my
report card read must talk less luckily
I didn't listen uh so for the past 25
years I have been working in television
that first is on air Talent more
recently as an executive focusing on dni
my work as a host has meant that I've
had to learn how to build meaningful
connections quickly with all kinds of
people from very different backgrounds
but it hasn't always been easy
there were neurological and
anthropological reasons why we gravitate
towards people that remind us of
ourselves there are unspoken codes of
familiarity codes that make us feel safe
we see this everywhere at conferences
lunch Halls parties even places of
worship
now there's a palpable feeling you get
when you don't connect with someone
don't worry I connect with you
it's awkward it's horrible and you just
want it to be over
but if you push through to find Common
Ground even if it's small just to get to
the Breakthrough that's when the magic
happens and something changes in both
people
a game-changing moment came for me early
on in my career when I was interviewing
a high-profile actress who shall remain
nameless she was starring in a movie
that was considered quite controversial
at the time and as a result had been
subjected to countless insulting
interviews so by the time I got around
to her things were tense and to make
matters worse we had absolutely nothing
in common to fall back on with her being
a high-profile A-list actress and me an
up-and-coming host
in that moment I knew I had two choices
one to carry on as we were which would
have been very uncomfortable for us both
and probably ended in the interview
being cut short
or two
try and find a breakthrough
now this was a well-seasoned actress and
it wasn't a particularly big budget
movie so I knew there had to be a bigger
reason as to why she'd accepted the role
in the first place so I decided to focus
on the character rather than the
controversy
and she immediately opened up and we
were able to have a deep and thoughtful
conversation it was actually enjoyable
for us both and she even thanked me at
the end
I learned so much from that encounter in
terms of what can happen when you don't
give up on an uncomfortable connection
and how powerful it can be for both
people
to this very day that moment still
serves as a template for me of what to
do whenever I find myself in a similar
situation
now if we are to move Society forward
this is a journey we all have to make
however I believe when it comes to the
workplace those with the most power and
agency must make the bigger sleep first
let me tell you about John landgrath the
CEO of FX
in 2015 variety magazine wrote a
scathing article about the least diverse
networks in America in relation to
directors and at the bottom of what was
a pretty bad list was FX out of the 168
episodes that had aired on FX and FXX
between 2014 and 2015.
88 were directed by white men
five percent by white women
seven percent by men of color and zero
percent by women of color
what happened next was interesting
instead of doing the usual corporate
thing of trying to defend the
indefensible rather land graph held up
his hand and pledged to diverse
creatives that he was going to act and
act quickly at that
so he and his team set about putting
together a concrete plan which included
a significant financial investment in
diverse creatives and in their suppliers
to find higher nurture and develop
diverse creatives from Industries where
there were transferable skills such as
music videos advertising and theater
within a year
land graph had turned FX from being the
least diverse Network in America to one
of the most and they had also managed to
increase their diverse directing pool to
just over half
critical and Commercial Success would
follow with hits such as Atlanta and
better things and there would also be an
upsurge in paid subscriptions
all because land graph stopped following
the crowd and instead decided to disrupt
in an inclusive way
I would call that Rockstar Behavior just
saying
now someone else I think is already a
rock star in more ways than one is
Gareth Southgate the current England
men's team football manager now before
becoming England manager Southgate was a
soccer player himself in the early 1990s
and 2000s and witnessed firsthand the
racist abuse his colleagues of color
were subjected to with monkey chants
being screamed at them during matches
and banana peels thrown onto the pitch
this searing knowledge would serve
Southgate well when he became the
custodian of the careers of a new
generation of England players
he knew he wanted to create a better
world for his players so he educated
himself on racial Injustice and then did
the same with the whole team by bringing
in Owen Eastwood a New Zealand
performance coach whose modern day
interpretation of the Maori philosophy
wakapapa we are all connected therefore
we all belong we become embedded in the
psyches of the whole team
now this England squad was like nothing
the country had ever seen before vibrant
with swagger as the young people would
say
um ethnically diverse and aligned to
movements such as BLM so when American
players led by Colin Kaepernick decided
to take the knee
southgate's players did so too in
solidarity
public backlash ensued
rather than bow to public pressure
Southgate penned an open letter to the
nation saying I have a responsibility to
The Wider Community to use my voice and
so do the players it's their duty to
continue to interact with the public or
matter such as equality inclusivity and
racial Injustice while using the power
of their voices to help put debates on
the table raise awareness and educate
that would soon be another Moment of
Truth
when three of his black players Marcus
rashford Makaya Sarco and Jaden Sancho
miss their penalties in the Euros finals
a barrage of Torrid racist abuse would
follow
again Southgate stepped up and not only
defended his players but took the blame
as coach
and the beautiful thing that also
happened was because of the education
piece that had gone before the whole
team rallied around the players seeing
an attack on one as an attack on them
all
the unequivocal solidarity the gov
Southgate has been able to create within
this England team is truly a profile in
Courage
the level of emotional intelligence and
understanding that he has displayed
means that he is now leading one of the
most Unified sports teams in modern
times
there's no reason this can't be a
template for business too
there are hierarchies of inclusion that
exist in every society
with those at the top on the inside and
those at the bottom cast outside
I grew up in London as the daughter of
African immigrants so I know what it
feels like to disrupt the world the way
it is and to break through
as a working-class black woman
somehow I had a different vision for
myself than the one the world had
created for me
fortunately we are now starting to see
more and more women of color progress
but it shouldn't be on us
now I know many of you will have noticed
because I saw your faces I know you did
that the list of Business Leaders that I
opened my talk with were all white men
and all white men from mainly affluent
backgrounds at that
that isn't a coincidence
no one group has a monopoly on Talent OR
ability
but as a result of the detrimental
impact of imperialism and colonialism up
until very recently at least from a
western perspective this group has had a
monopoly on access and opportunity
we are heading into some very turbulent
times economically and socially we're at
a Crossroads too
in the past difficult times has often
meant the diversity and inclusion has
been put on a back burner
I would argue now is the time for us to
dig deeper
we know inclusion grows the bottom line
and the leaders who truly understand
this will be the ones that not only win
but when the right way
so
these innovators These Guys these rock
stars who have taken on everything from
Computing to Commerce to coffee
wouldn't it be cool to see them disrupt
in equity too
to look at the world the way it is just
like Gareth and John did
and say to themselves nah that's not it
I don't know about you but those are the
kind of rock stars I want to see thank
you
too much